in this lecture we explore civic cults
whose ceremonies took place publicly
worship of athena in athens will serve
as our example we will then visit
demeter both in athens
and at a losis a small town not far from
athens
as well as dionysus whose worship spread
not just in greece but also to italy and
beyond
and through these visitations discover
the world of mystery religions
cults that required secret initiation
away from the prying and profane eyes of
the public
the sometimes vaunted patience or
tolerance of the polytheistic state
as we shall see did not always permit
and sometimes even persecuted
such worshipers especially those who
followed
dionysus the god of intoxication
but first athena polios in the city of
athens
athena earned her epithet polios when
she became
the patron goddess of the polis or city
this occurred according to myth when
eric thornius
also called erecthius decided a contest
between athena and poseidon when the two
of them vied for precedence
athena offered the olive poseidon
salt water eric thonius the judge
who chose the olive and thus athena
could also claim partial descent from
the virgin goddess
despite her virginity erichthonius's
father hephaestus god of the forge
attempted to rape athena he was
unsuccessful
but during the assault he ejaculated on
athena's leg
i agree this is grotesque and
distasteful but
to continue the semen fell to the ground
and erichthonius was conceived in the
earth
gay with a hard g in greek but in
english we pronounce
a g followed by e as g as in
geology geography geothermal
gay was a goddess in her own right even
dirt is divine athena took this child
conceived in violence and shame hit him
in a box
and entrusted the box to the daughters
of key crops
key crops was then king of athens
she gave them instructions not to look
inside
but are you surprised key crops's
daughters
peaked to their horror and to their
destruction
they discovered a remarkably beautiful
child surrounded by vicious serpents
erichthonius survived the daughters of
key crops
did not ericthonia subsequently grew up
in athena's temple
and became king after key crops
poseidon i fear never had a chance in
that contest
and athena became athena polios
that is city athena of athens
eric thornius also established according
to legend the pan-athenaic festival
the festival of all athens a yearly
celebration of athena's birthday on the
28th of hecatombien
a month that fell somewhere between july
and august
this was a hot time of year which is
perhaps why preliminary festivities
began in the evening beforehand with all
night singing
and dance performances by choruses of
girls and boys
this was the pannicus literally the
all-nighter
and dawn was only the midpoint as the
festival proper
began with daybreak
the pan-ethania proper was celebrated in
two varieties
a smaller or lesser and a larger or
greater
the lesser version of the panathinia was
celebrated annually
for three years and every fourth year a
greater
panathenaia subsumed the activities of
the lesser panathia
by adding days for preliminary contests
the ancient greeks were a notoriously
competitive people so
festivities included musical contests
poetry recitations gymnastic contests
horse and chariot racing pyrrhic dances
pyrrhic dances we may note in passing
were a sort of
war dance performed by naked men who
wore
nothing more than a helmet on their
heads and a shield on their left arm
athena may have been a virgin goddess
but she was also a
fierce goddess of war nakedness did not
carry the same shame
among ancient greeks that it has among
monotheistic religions
and on the day following the festival
there was a supplementary boat race
these contests could for the lesser
panathinia be squeezed into a day or two
for the greater panathinia the contest
could stretch on for
three days or more all these contests
were
like the nocturnal choruses of the
pennicus preliminary
and they serve to determine who would
lead the main event
on the 28th of hecatombian athena's
birthday indeed
exciting as all these events must have
been the centerpiece of the festival
was a lavish parade or to phrase it more
solemnly a procession followed
by animal sacrifices of cows bowls sheep
and rams with subsequent feasting on
sacrificial meat
which was distributed according to deems
or district
but before we feast let's look at the
parade which was depicted on the
parthenon
and which we may now find in the remains
of the freeze on the exterior wall of
the nause
that is the portion of the temple that
enclosed the statue of athena
this low relief freeze in the
traditional interpretation
depicts the stages of the procession as
well as the people who marched
on the west end we observe riders
preparing their horses
if we proceed from the west toward the
east
we observe riders on their horses a
chariot race old men musicians
porters and sacrificial animals the
north side
features water bearers sheep and cattle
the south side tablet bearers and cattle
on the east side we observe girls heroes
gods and a new cloak or peplos
for athena the images
from the parthenon freezes one may view
the
dubiously obtained originals in the
british museum
give us an idea of the pan-anthonia
again according to their traditional
interpretation
but we cannot expect them to give us
exact details
and to cast further shade on these
illustrations
a recent interpretation argues that they
pertain not so much to athena
as to eric thornius but time is too
short for that
let us turn to literary reports from
ancient authors who can help us imagine
the details we are told
that the whole population turned out for
the procession
citizens and resident aliens alike
though i note that slaves are not
mentioned so
perhaps it was just the whole free
population
the victors of the various contests led
the way
followed by sacrificial officiants
officers of the army dignitaries who had
reached old age
young men and this is noteworthy dear
students of gender relations
many girls and women who escaped the
confines of the house for this religious
occasion
they carried baskets and it was the
women's job to manufacture each year
the new pep loss or cloak for athena
this job too took women out of the house
as a pep loss could not be manufactured
in a few hours or even a few days
religion sanctioned civic religion
granted women opportunities to escape
the confines of the domestic sphere
and the annual festival of the
panathenia was not the only such
occasion that offered this opportunity
women served as priestesses of local
gods
visited shrines of asclepius in hopes of
cures
and enjoyed some forms of worship which
were exclusively reserved for women
the greatest example of exclusively
female worship is the thesmaphoria
which had which was a three-day festival
in honor of demeter
goddess of grain but goddess of grain
fails to capture the reverence in which
demeter was held
the ancient historian diodorus tells us
that demeter's gift
is what makes human life possible
at all athena protected
demeter granted life itself she was also
a model mother
but more on that in a moment to prepare
for demeter's worship upper-class women
to whom the rights were confined
and perhaps only married women abstained
from sexual relations for nine days
and possibly resorted to special herbs
to reduce sexual desires
at least according to our male sources
the three-day festival consisted of
three days away from home
camping on the ground and began with a
nocturnal procession
during which the women sang lewd songs
and made obscene
comments obscenity we may note was
like nakedness tolerated if not enjoyed
in certain religious contexts if the
comedies of aristophanes are any guide
the gods even tolerated a satirical
roast at their expense
three days away from the strictures of
the women's quarters
at home were probably a welcome respite
the rituals were kept secret but in
addition to
the camping we hear of sacrifices that
included throwing
pigs into chasms one would like to know
more
ancient male authors offered guesses
just as they offered guesses about other
exclusively female rights
but the secrets of the thesmophoria
remain
well kept remarkably
the el usinian mysteries of demeter
which were open to both men
and women also remain hidden despite the
many thousands who were initiated over
the centuries
no clear account has come down to us
demeter was the mother of
persephone who was also known as cora
the maiden
persephone was captured by hades to
serve as his wife in the underworld
and when persephone went missing a
distraught demeter searched for her
daughter
until she learned her daughter's fate
after that
demeter was grief-stricken and angry
the roman poet ovid describes the scene
the goddess tore her unkempt locks and
smote
her breast again and again with her
hands
she did not know as yet where her child
was
still she reproached all lands calling
them ungrateful and unworthy of the gift
of grain
so there with angry hands she broke in
pieces the plows that turned the earth
and in her rage she gave to destruction
farmers and cattle alike
and bade the plowed fields to betray
their trust
and blighted the seed the fertility of
this land
famous throughout the world lay false to
its good name
the crops died in early blade now too
much heat
now too much rain destroying them stars
and winds were baleful and greedy birds
ate up the seed
as soon as it was sown tears and thorns
and stubborn grasses choked
the wheat to make a long story short
demeter eventually convinced zeus to
compel his brother to return persephone
alas persephone had eaten some
pomegranate seeds while in the
underworld
so she was each year compelled to remain
as many months below the earth
as she had eaten seeds when persephone
is above the earth with her mother
demeter is full of joy and blesses the
earth with fertility
when the daughter is with hades below
the earth her mother mourns and nothing
grows
this explains the seasons and provides
the backdrop to the mysteries
that took place originally only at
demeter sanctuary
in lucis although initiation
was open to both citizens and foreigners
one could not simply
show up at the beginning of the annual
10-day festival in september a would-be
initiate
had to arrive early and make
arrangements initiates had to find
an instructor or mr gogos who had
already been
initiated the mr gogus would test
the votery for fitness and present the
applicant to the priest or hierophant
preparations included fasting during the
daytime
eating only at night abstaining from
certain foods including of course
pomegranates
but also beans at the beginning of the
festival
voteries gathered at sunset and
proceeded on foot
to the sea where they would bathe on the
days that followed
there were sacrifices all night vigils
that also went by the name
pandikis and eventually a trek on foot
to ellucis which if done efficiently
would take about four hours to cover 11
miles but generally took
much longer
did the fasting the all-night vigils
have a psychological effect
one can imagine when the night for
initiation came
before being allowed to enter the
initiate said
according to the christian author
clement of alexandria
i fasted i drank the potion
consisting of barley cheese wine and
magical drugs i took from the chest
having done my task i have placed in the
basket
and from the basket into the chest
the initiate was the initiate was then
we are told instructed in what happened
to persephone
and learned things from the priest that
could not be repeated
in fact divulging the mysteries of
persephone was punishable by death
and we have accounts of people who were
brought up on charges
including the tragedian aeschylus who
was acquitted of having divulged the
mysteries in his plays
the highest grade of initiation came a
year later when it was possible to see
the sacred objects whatever they may
have been
ancient christian authors have left some
guesses for our consideration
clement of alexandria writes
i must strip bear their holy things and
utter
the unspeakable are these sacred objects
not
sesame cakes pyramid and spherical cakes
cakes with many navels also balls of
salt and a serpent
the mystic sign of dionysus bassareas
are they not also pomegranates fig
branches fennel stalks ivy leaves round
cakes and poppies
these are their holy things in addition
there are the unutterable symbols of gay
themis
marjoram a lamp a sword and a woman's
comb
which is a euphemistic expression used
in the mysteries
for a woman's secret parts what manifest
shamelessness
so female genitalia according to the
outraged ancient
christian father were the most sacred
object
a grain stalk is another and more sober
guess at the most sacred object
whatever the objects may have been the
sun
shone brighter for the initiates and
they spoke of a greater peace and
understanding about what lay in the next
world
after their earthly life came to an end
and this makes sense
persephone could offer assistance when
when the deceased
entered hades despite the attempts of
christian emperors to shut down
ellucis the mysteries remained popular
until 394
ce when the sanctuary was destroyed
by a barbarian invasion
another mystery religion that attracted
the attention
not just of christian moralists but also
the state authorities of the
pre-christian world
was the worship of dionysus the god of
wine
and intoxication his mysteries too
are worth a look dionysus
the romans called him bacchus or liber
was the son of zeus
his mother emily was mortal and had been
tricked
by hera who disguised herself as a
friendly old wim
woman into asking zeus to make love to
her
the way he did to hera
could jolt zeus to do just that alas
zeus in all his glory is a thunderbolt
semilly died in a flash of lightning she
died
but zeus but zeus saved the sun in her
womb
by sewing him up in his thigh until the
fetus came to term
dionysus because he was born not just
from
a mortal woman's womb but was also born
again
from zeus's thigh was immortal he was
the twice born god
and he introduced according to myth the
cultivation of the vine
that is grapes viticulture the raw
materials for wine
dionysus was also a jealous god and
persecuted
those who refused to worship him
our most famous representation of
dionysus derives from the tragedy of
euripides the bacchi
which was produced in 405 bce
the year before euripides died
when the tragedy opens bacchus as he is
frequently called
in the play is traveling through greece
to make himself known
as the son of zeus but upon reaching his
mother's home town of thieves bacchus
encounters skeptics who deny his
divinity
his mother's sister agave does not
believe that bacchus is a god
nor does agave's son pentheus the
current king of thebes
bacchus has driven the women of thebes
into a frenzy and force them to worship
him
and they celebrate his rights on mount
sitheron pentheus is outraged and
completely hostile
to the new religion
in the time of euripides the worship of
bacchus was a long-established and
accepted addition to the worship of the
gods
this seems not always to have been the
case according to myth
when backus came back to greece he had
to
struggle to establish his new religion
cadmus former king of thebes father of
bacchus's mother's emily
and father of pentheus's mother agave
warns penteus
the blind prophet tyreseus warns
pentheus as well
pentheus does not listen to the warnings
of his grandfather
or of the prophet and he attempts to
imprison
bacchus who claims to be
only a worshipper of bacchus
bacchus however blinds pentheus to
reality
pentheus ties up a bull instead of
bacchus
bacchus then sends an earthquake to
destroy
pentheus's palace
meanwhile a messenger arrives with news
of what the frenzied women are up to on
mount sitharod
pantheous is not pleased by what he
hears
backus then tricks pentheus into
dressing up like a woman
so that he can go see for himself what
the women
are doing once pentheus is on the
mountain
bacchus makes sure that the women catch
sight of pentheus
the women tear pentheus to pieces agave
still frenzied
carries the head of her own son in
triumph to town
women who worship bacchus were called
mainads
they were often depicted carrying a long
stick or fennel stalk topped with ivy
this was the thirstus and their rights
included
not only gathering in an all-female
group
only women could be maine ads if a group
included both men and women it was a
thea sauce
they preferred to gather in remote
mountain spots for while
dancing or bossia but also ripping wild
animals to pieces and then eating the
flesh of these wild animals raw
they imagined that the god was himself
mystically present in the animal
this was the so-called pleasure of
eating raw flesh or
homophagus chorus greek vases depict for
us
main ads in a state of frenzy as well as
mixed groups of worshipers in a thea
sauce
fennel stalks are thirsty in hand
as this brief sketch may show worship of
bacchus was at least according to the
myth
perceived as a threat to male control
over religious practice
women removed themselves from the city
and participated in emotional rituals
removed from the male gaze in male
control
pantheous himself remarks how shameful
it is for the men of thieves
that their women engage in such
practices
one did more than tell stories about
bacchus and antiquity
he was worshiped with real and sometimes
extravagant rights
in many places his worship also differed
from the calmer worship of
of the gods of olympus consisting in the
sacrifice of animals by state priests
athens however eventually incorporated
worship of dionysus into its yearly
schedule of festivals
and thus provides an example of how
cities
tamed him so to speak
indeed a state that had numerous gods
could always adopt additional gods and
most states
tolerated numerous other gods if
worshippers
stayed out of trouble but the state did
not always tolerate all gods
indiscriminately
and mystery cults sometimes came under
suspicion
especially those which like the worship
of dionysus
brought women out of the house at night
for wine drinking
and while dancing without male
supervision
as we shall soon see looking ahead to
rome
even after dionysus had been tamed in
greece
back worship could still upset
polytheists
elsewhere but what was the advantage
of joining such a non-state cult
the advantages according to the cults
themselves
were many including fertility in this
world
and assistance in the next world cult
initiates received help from the god of
the cult
when facing the judges of the underworld
in afterlife
let alone eternal bliss was not
guaranteed
by state gods cult gods on the other
hand like bacchus
because he had been born once of a
mortal woman and then a second time
into eternal life as an immortal god
could help an individual fix things in
the next world
but only if the individual were a
properly initiated member of his cult
there were also advantages in this world
which were not inconsiderable
and which we have already mentioned wild
mountain dancing
raw animal flesh and wine that is
alcohol
intoxication in mixed gatherings in the
theaters
this could lead to sex which is not to
say that sex could not have occurred at
same-sex gatherings as well
and sometimes violence there is for
example archaeological evidence
that suggests ritual whipping for
purification
wall paintings from pompeii seem to
illustrate this
but this is not certain state cults
gave citizens membership in the civic
body
mystery religions gave people membership
in a personal cult
that is a cult that addressed individual
and personal needs
participation in the cult in this world
allowed one to transcend
normal life one experienced a temporary
membership within a community of fellow
worshipers
bringing a potentially blissful feeling
of belonging
altogether a rather attractive package
why did the state sometimes object
women who were citizens and had sex
outside marriage threatened property
relations
which descended patrilineally and
gatherings without proper supervision
were tantamount to political conspiracy
and in 186 bce the roman state outlawed
the worship of bacchus for these very
reasons
hundreds of or perhaps thousands of
worshipers
were crucified along the roads leading
to rome
despite these efforts the roman state
too however eventually abandoned its
struggle against the followers of
bacchus
and a milder version of the worship of
bacchus
was accommodated in rome
earlier in the century scholars often
compared mystery cults with christianity
christianity requires initiation baptism
the initiate becomes a member of a
community of fellow believers
and abandons other groups and forms of
worship
additionally early christians met at
night and drank wine
these were all night prayer vigils with
communion christians were also like
worshipers of bacchus
before them also accused of cannibalism
ritual murder intoxication illicit sex
and political conspiracy
another similarity was the promise of
help in the afterlife
current scholarship nevertheless tends
to reject the similarity of christianity
with ancient mystery religions for two
reasons
scholars who made the comparison often
had a hidden agenda
they wanted to attack the uniqueness of
christian and jewish monotheism
also mystery religions varied from city
to city and were often integrated with
the many other gods of antiquity
much scholarship failed to appreciate
these differences
the question of how unique jewish
monotheism and christianity may have
been
we shall postpone for the future because
we
dear students have run out of time
what have we done we have looked at the
civic cult of athena polios
in athens the exclusively female worship
of demeter
at the thesmaphoria the mysteries of
demeter atolus
and the perceived threats of dionysus
and baptic worship
in all these forms of worship we see too
that there were opportunities for women
to form communities among women
as well as some opportunities for mixed
groups to form communities
apart from their families and the state
initiation into mystery religions could
also assist individuals on the lonely
journeys they faced into the next world
when they died but there is still more
in our next lecture we'll look at
orpheus who harrowed hell
in search of his wife and then returned
to preach
same-sex love to men we'll also discuss
the doctrines of some early skeptics
who rejected the beliefs and practices
of their fellow citizens and kinsmen
sometimes at the cost of their lives
until then
dear disciples of ancient religions and
cult practices
may your days be auspicious your nights
restful and your health
excellent
[Music]
you